the jurogan experience
what are other sci-fi favorites of yours
alien alien yeah that's why i was really
excited when i heard that you were
at least potentially at one point in
time thinking about doing an alien yeah
it would have been cool what happened
it's just you know just studio politics
and the um
i do i do think that the way that
chappie was received probably played a
role in me not working on alien uh
but you know it's it's ridley's world
that he created and it's like it should
be his to do what he wants with so it
it's it's all good
yeah i get that
but still would have been fun yeah i
would have been fun for me as well i
mean the the thing that i i would have
really enjoyed about it was sigourney
weaver was really down for what i'd
written and she
that the main thing to me was even
though i like alien 3 and i love fincher
as a director i just wanted a version of
of the continuation of what happened
after aliens
and for newt to be alive and for you
know for ripley to continue that story
um and it was sort of based on that idea
is the kid who played newt how old is
she now
um
i
i mean in my story she was she was in
her uh kind of mid-20s um
i mean in reality i mean alien just
aliens just turned 35 so she must be you
know
like 44 or something isn't that wild
yeah it's wild when you find out that
the movie the original was from the 70s
79 yeah like what yeah
it seems so much more current yeah than
in 1970 i mean that's one of the things
that's amazing about it is is how
timeless it is yeah you know and and
also just i mean a lot of it i saw it in
a theater a couple of years ago and i
couldn't believe just the quality of
everything you know it's really amazing
how well it was filmed i accidentally
watched the blu-ray version of aliens
and it's kind of hilarious because in
the blu-ray version things that were not
meant to be hd are now hd
so there's a scene where the spaceships
are lined up and there's clearly a mural
of spaceships in the background it looks
so [ __ ] fake oh you mean a matte
painting yeah so when they're in the
solaco when they're in the when they're
in the the military ship the big one yes
right i think i think i know what you
mean it looks so corny i'm like no
because there's you know there's like
this physical
ship yeah and then behind it it's just
some [ __ ] it's like it's so clear
that they used you know they expected
like focus and you know the kind of
graininess of film right mask that yeah
matt paintings pre-computer graphics
were done on panes of glass and so um i
mean
in a way aliens is like an
using the technology that they had at
the time is actually like totally
incredible but i know i do know what
you're saying though i mean for for
audiences now weaned on the stuff that
we're that we have access to you know
these techniques are so dated but it
would be a large pane of glass like a
shower piece of glass and then they
would paint
what they want the set to look like
and shoot through it
with your other real environments as
well that's why the shot's always locked
off right they're always stable
obviously you can't move right so yeah
aliens was interesting
by itself if alien didn't exist
the problem with aliens is these
creatures are so bumbling and easy to
kill
like in the first movie that thing was
so clever pure terror yeah pure terror
so clever and and so good at sneaking up
on people i mean i think the thing that
cameron did with the second film was
pretty amazing though in the way that he
was he made it he made it militaristic
it
changed the the context and so i think
because of that and also there was the
kind of vietnam war
high technology low technology sort of
parable at play yes um
so it was two forces you know in which
case it makes the aliens be more there's
there's an abundance of them right um
but i i i almost like both films equally
i think
both both approaches
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify